[Musique]
le groupe Thalès est un groupe important
spécialisé dans la défense et il est
situé sur le territoire de Saint-Quentin
en Yvelines et avec moi Michel Blancard
bonjour
responsable des lignes électroniques sur
le site d'Élancourt au sein du groupe
Thalès alors c'est quoi le chronique
tout simplement alors l'optronic en deux
mots c'est l'association de l'optique et
d'électronique donc on va avoir des
capteurs comme la photographie et on va
avoir des traitements qui vont permettre
d'améliorer les rendus et d'avoir des
fonctions complémentaires et alors vous
vous occupez de l'autre unique de
l'avion de combat de l'armée de l'air
française le Rafale oui oui alors le
Rafale entre autres d'autres avions
également mais oui donc nous avons des
produits phares sur le sur le secteur le
pote de désignation laser talios ou
l'OSF y est resté qui équipe tous les
deux leur a fait alors quels sont est-ce
que vous pouvez nous décrire justement
ces deux produits alors oui je peux
essayer de vous décrire rapidement donc
le poids de l'utilisation laser ça va
être un pote qui va permettre de faire
de l'imagerie donc fournir du
renseignement image au pilote également
de la désignation de cible et de
l'identification donc en fait c'est les
yeux du pilote et ils vont porter plus
loin pour lui permettre de réaliser ses
missions au-delà des portées habituelles
et sur le sfirst on est plutôt sur la
notion de radar donc en fait on s'est un
radar roptronique on va scruter l'espace
en face de l'avion détecter les menaces
et lui permettent de les identifier
visuellement par une image
[Musique]
alors tu as laissé historiquement situé
sur le territoire de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et plus
précisément à Élancourt c'est 2000
personnes au quotidien qui travaillent
dans les locaux sur la partie
électronique oui c'est devenu un peu
plus de 2000 personnes oui et 1000
personnes qui sont consacrées à ces deux
produits là alors ces deux à la ligne de
produits en général mais oui si on
englobe puisqu'en fait la particularité
du site c'est que l'on couvre la
totalité du cycle on développe les
produits on fabrique les produits on
fait le soutien de ces produits et on
gère les programmes sur la durée totale
donc effectivement on est capable
d'adresser depuis la phase de conception
jusqu'à la phase de soutien concrètement
c'est quoi l'activité de ces personnes
qui développent ces produits alors on a
une population essentiellement
d'ingénieurs après on va avoir
différents métiers électroniques bien
entendu puisque vous imaginez bien qu'il
y a énormément d'électronique sur ce
type de produit informatique puisqu'on a
des algorithmes qui tournent et des
logiciels qui tournent dedans tout ce
qui est bureau d'études mécanique
parce que on va être fixé sous un avion
d'armes donc avec des contraintes
mécaniques importantes
optique bien entendu puisque le métier
de lochronique allie l'optique j'en
oublie sûrement et je m'en excuse déjà
auprès de ces gens-là et effectivement
donc c'est une population assez large
dans des métiers qui vont être la phase
de conception donc partir d'études
jusqu'à la réalisation de prototype leur
certification pour pouvoir voler sous
les avions de nos clients la fabrication
puisse une fois que le Produit est
défini et qualifié il va être vendu donc
là on va produire ces équipements en
série pour les pour les forces et le
soutien donc en cas de panne de pouvoir
assurer le soutien de nos équipements et
c'est de l'ingénierie de précision parce
que là on parle vraiment de militaires
de défense et forcément il faut que ce
soit certifié par les différents corps
d'armée vos différents clients alors on
a une exigence de rigueur bien entendu
effectivement puisque on fait des
produits du haute technologies et on a
un mélange de technologie de la
mécanique de l'électronique donc oui il
y a il y a un domaine global appréhender
à titre d'exemple sur 2023 on cherche à
recruter plus de 400 personnes juste sur
le site d'Élancourt donc ça ça vous
donne une idée de de la croissance et de
la dynamique du secteur
type de poste alors tout poste
parti technique mécanique électronique
gestion de programme vraiment
toute la partie que je vous ai décrites
peut-être un peu plus sur la partie
développement effectivement
effectivement avec des ingénieurs
diplômés plutôt électronique
informatique optique mécanique et si ces
activités vous intéressent n'hésitez pas
à aller chercher plus d'informations et
peut-être à postuler sur le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
merci Michel Blanquart merci je vous en
prie je rappelle que vous êtes le
responsable de la ligne de production
octronique au sein du groupe Thalès à
Élancourt merci